planning a revival near downtown the
community came together tonight to get a
look into the future of huntred circle
park
thanks for joining us i'm denise valdez
and i'm brian loftis the park near
maryland parkway in charleston has been
closed since 2018 due to a rise in crime
in part now there are efforts to bring
it back to life
madison kimbrough joining us from city
hall tonight after hearing what
neighbors think of these new plans
madison
yes residents in the historic hunt ridge
neighborhood are ready to see their park
back in action as they met here and city
leaders here at
city council to talk about revivals and
also get their input on this
long awaited reveal
we need recreation more than ever to
help in our restoration
and also most importantly build our
community at one point a staple in the
las vegas community
hunt ridge circle park has had its ups
and downs it was built in 1941 but has
since been closed the last few years
due to public safety concerns monday
night city leaders joined residents at
city hall to talk about improvements at
the park
and a timeline for reopening we're
looking at a 18 to 24 month process
because we're going to have
continued meetings that we'll plan that
will
the architect can offer some renderings
the community can have some input
some of the amenities suggested
including building a dog park
gym stations community garden and a
gated fence with an access code
residents gave their feedback online
many who say they're just eager to get
this park
up and running again we moved to the
neighborhood a couple years ago
and we you know have been missing the
open space right it's sad to see
so many trees and the turf and just see
it from the car as opposed to being able
to
enter the space i'd like to see now that
people are coming
back out to associate with each other
it's made and built in a way that people
can interact with each other
councilwoman diaz adds that they plan to
have several meetings ahead of the
park's launch
with the next one being in a couple
months and then again this reopening is
planned
for reporting live from city hall
madison kimbrough 8 news now